Um, okay, let's go to our caller from the,
let's go to the six one, two area code. Who's
calling today from six one two. Yeah, that's
you. Who's this?
My name is Stephen. Hi Dave.
Hey, how are you doing?
Great man. Uh, well where do I start? First
off, thank you so much for just being out
there and just giving an informative kind
of opinion. You know, like a lot of times
you get like a newscast and you feel like,
oh, weird vibe from them, but with you, like
I really feel like you're trying to give the
truth out there and trying to give an honest
answer.
Thank you. Appreciate it.
My pleasure. Okay, so here's what's up. So
obviously like I was always into politics
growing up with on the debate team. Um, and
definitely knew like Republicans, like they
voted because like they thought God was appointing
their officials and stuff. Okay. So I always
had a hard time trying to follow Republican
views cause a lot of times when I had my friends
they'd be like, I'm Republican because it's
the right choice. And there's always this
scheme of, of the right thing. So I just recently
started dating a girl for about, well we've
been dating for year and it's great, you know,
and she's always like, you're super into politics
and I just don't get that. Come to find out
like her father was super religious and they
really tied in the fact that they wore religious
and republican and those two are tied together.
And now it's been a year in cheese and I'm
progressive by the way, like straight progressive
like I want everything needs to change.
You know, like the system is broken, you know,
it's out for money making schemes and there's
things that need to change and I want to hear
plans to do so. So she's been way more open
nowadays with the way I see things because
she just sees the practicality of making things
better for the right reasons. You know what
I mean? And nowadays she likes to admit that
being, being her views Republican and religion
were tied together that she saw being in the
Repo Repo Republican party as a religious
cult and we, we just started entertained that
idea nowadays and trying to talk to others
and try to come to a table. Cause like you
definitely have opened my eyes to that as
like maybe I don't have to see their abuse
but like we should at least encourage the
conversation. What I'm trying to bring up
today is where do you separate for them? Their
passion for their God, which I have to honor
because I don't have a way to disprove them.
Their passion for their God, with their connection
to politics like I do, I should I just write
it off that they're religious and that they're
going to have their views no matter what.
Or is there a way that, can I have a conversation
with them that they can start seeing me as
not just the bad guy, but somebody who wants
to have a progressive agenda.
Okay. So listen, th there's a bunch of different
stuff here. So just for context, am I right
that, I'm guessing from your accent, you're
from like the northern Midwest somewhere,
is that where all this was going on?
Oh, for sure. Yeah. I'm sorry. Am I throwing
a heavy accent out there? I'm sorry man.
No, you're not throwing anything. I'm just
trying to understand. I gathered that that
must be the part of the country you're talking
about. So, so are you like what in Wisconsin,
Minnesota, something like that.
I, I'm born Wisconsin, but moved to the twin
cities. So now I'm the twin city EITs,
so correct me if I'm wrong, but the real,
the Repub, the religious republicans in that
area, it's, these are not like Kentucky evangelicals,
right? You're talking about a different type
of religiosity.
You would be, that is such a great point to
make out because here it's more of like a
cloak. Like you don't really see it as right
off the bat. It's more you get to know somebody
and then three days of, of getting the notes
and when you find out they're a devout Christian,
where I feel like Kentucky, you kind of see
it more right off the, off the cuff.
Yeah. So listen, here's my advice and take
it, take it for what you're paying for. It
is nothing. Right? Um, I, I don't, first of
all you said you, you have to respect their
God because you can't disprove it. I think
that that's the wrong approach. I think that
you don't have to respect their, they're god
any more than anything else that no one else
can prove. And what I mean by that is they
are free to believe anything they want privately.
Their religion can be valuable to them in
whatever ways it's valuable to them. But it's
okay to set a line and say your arbitrary
self-professed beliefs have no place in figuring
out what policy should be in a country that
has separation of church and state. So first
of all, I don't know that I would be as deferential
to the religious component is maybe you're
suggesting now of course this is your girlfriend's
family. You don't want to alienate them either.
But w w what I would try to do is I don't
know that I would be slicing and dicing things
into which views are informed by religion
and which are not. I would just speak about
your progressive values because those are
positive values. Those are values that bring
good things to the table for people. And I
don't think you should put yourself in a position
to have to present your progressive views
as a counter or alternative or could their
religiosity.
Absolutely. You know, we always will have
that talk and they'll kind of throw their
heart about it, you know, and you feel that
kind of love for it. And then you just add,
um, what I usually do is just file it. Say,
you know, like there's flat out in the amendment
that says there will be a separation of church
and state. Right. And you know, like obviously
it's, it's, it's ballsy to say this to somebody
you, you know, but the way you pointed out
makes it a lot easier, um, to go about and
you know, the next day is why, why should
I lose my progressive agenda just because
this person's getting emotional of something.
I can just agree with them on.
So, but stepping, here's what are most interested
in are, have there been arguments with her
family because they are right wingers in your
left winger?
Well, we haven't even come to the table about
where we sit. Oh, like her, her father, my
girlfriend and I have had this conversation
and I've had to talk to her, her friends who
are Republicans and even Maga supporters,
which I would even say I separate that group
from fro. Yeah, yeah. You know what I mean?
Yeah. I separate them from Republicans because
those Republicans who I want to talk about
their values and figured that out. And then
there's the dude who was wearing the hat and
screaming like it's a football game. Right.
I don't care about that guy.
I got Ya. Alright, Stephen, listen, it sounds
like quite a situation you have going there.
Appreciate the call and uh, you know, let
me know how it goes with them.
Absolutely. Thanks Dave.
All right, thanks very much. Take care of.